trouve tout de suite karim hakiki qui
est avec nous en direct de l'elysée
karim on évoquer donc cette intervention
du chef de l'état français aux côtés de
charles michel président du conseil
européen macky sall président du sénégal
président de l'union africaine et
président ghanéen akufo addo un
président de la cedeao également et
qu'est ce qu'on va retenir quelles sont
les grandes lignes de cette intervention
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on a appris de
plus qu'on ne savait déjà hier
on a pris d'abord les modalités et
comment allait se faire ce retrait
redéploiement le prétend de la
république accompagné des trois autres
présidents étaient tous d'accord unanime
pour dire qu'il s'agit là d'un
redéploiement à la fois des forces
françaises met en relation en
collaboration avec les forces
européennes mais également l'implication
directe avec les forces africaines
d'ailleurs le président de la république
emmanuel macron l'a dit il faudrait
intéresser beaucoup plus les populations
civiles locales à la lutte
antiterroriste et non plus jouer ce rôle
de gendarme de l'afrique jean michel lui
a appelé de ses voeux le à un accord
européen d'ailleurs les européens vont
se retrouver avec les chefs d'état
africains tout à l'heure en début
d'après midi à bruxelles pour définir le
cadre de cette nouvelle coopération nous
avons appris également que ce retrait
était prévu d'après ce que disait le
président de la république emmanuel
macron c'est-à-dire ce glissement de la
force basque cab arcanes vers la force
takouba cette force européenne de deux
forces spéciales qui pourrait intervenir
partout dans la région et puis nous
avons appris une deuxième chose
également c'est que pour le président de
la république française les bases au
mali notamment ou dans la région du
sahel les bases militaires françaises ne
seront plus d'actualité
il s'agira d'être présent en appui au
soutien avec les forces africaines pour
d'abord les former et ensuite la les
impliquer dans la lutte antiterroriste
ensuite le président de la république a
récusé l'échec de la force barkan en
tout cas l'échec de la de la présence
française au mali en disant que d'abord
ça a permis de stopper cette avancée
jihadistes
avec l'instauration de l'opération
serval des djihadistes qui marchaient
vers la ville bamako le président
emmanuel macron la dire sans
l'intervention française et à la demande
des autorités maliennes et africaine eh
bien l'état nation du mali se serait
effondré il s'agit de continuer la lutte
antiterroriste mais le président de la
république a quand même
il a quand même dit que en fait on
réalité son retrait allait poser deux
problèmes d'abord le problème
sécuritaire et logistique des armées
françaises et européennes et puis
pendant que les armées françaises de
barkan se retire il bien la lutte
antiterroriste sur place ne sera pas
assuré il a dit que cela était de la
faute de la junte au pouvoir au mali qui
a décidé de ne plus avoir de priorité en
tout cas sa priorité dans la lutte anti
terroriste n'est pas évidente d'après le
président de la république merci
beaucoup carrément effectivement